all of pmq is really focused on net
migration
there are a couple of lines of attack in
there from labor the first one was about
broken promises about a government that
promised in 2019 to bring down overall
net migration numbers it was at 22 600
000 back then it was a half a million uh
in the year to June 2021 and we expect
it tomorrow to go from anything between
650 000 up to 1 million so there was an
easy attack line really there on broken
promises but the second line of attack
which is interesting because I think it
speaks to what Labor's approach will be
going into a general election wasn't to
actually focus on overall numbers per se
but on work visas and kierstarma laying
into the Prime Minister on the amount of
work visas the government were issuing
he then used that to choose the Tories
of having a Tory low wage economy as he
put it saying that uh the conservative
party was still importing cheap labor
now this is really important Kimberly
because we have I think about seven
million economically inactive people in
the country of work in age and a lot of
the budget last year by Jeremy Hunt was
to try and bring those people back into
the labor force be it young parents with
support for child care uh be it changes
to pension pot allowances for some very
wealthy Professionals in their 50s
because the government recognized this
as a really big problem and I think what
you can see in how kirstalmer was
arguing that in pmqs is that what he
will develop is a policy I imagine
around driving up wages in order to
bring net migration down by encouraging
people back in to the workforce by a
fairer deal I imagine that's what he
would say
um and for us you see that that was
uncomfortable the the net migration
figures are deeply uncomfortable uh for
him and he doesn't really want to tackle
it head-on
what he did do was attack labor saying
you have no ideas on net migration and
he also
um attacked uh kirstarma for still
wanting freedom of movement now that's
actually inaccurate case farmer has made
it very clear that he does not want a
return to freedom of movement and has
ruled out elements of changing the
post-brexit trading deal with the
European Union in order to avoid that so
in that the Prime Minister quoting maybe
historic things that kirstarma had said
rather than current policy the one
glimmer of hope or light that uh the
Prime Minister had in that prime
minister's questions were those IMF
upgrades so the international monetary
fund upgrade in forecast for the UK
economy uh this week and and when he was
in a tight spot he went back to that and
of course when it comes to his
five-point plan stopping illegal
migration via small boats clearly one of
them but two others are on growing the
economy and halving inflation and on
growing the economy he at least had
something positive to put back on the
table there when attacked by kirstama
but for labor they clearly see the
failure to grip immigration when that
was a key promise of taking back control
is a fertile attack line for them into
the next general election and you saw
with that student visa urgent statement
the government now trying to find ways
to drive down migration numbers and and
reduce the number of dependents allowed
to come on student visas it is one way
that they're trying to do that so they
are acknowledging if you like ahead of
those figures coming out uh tomorrow
that they have to find ways of driving
down net migration so that when the
figures come out they can at least say
well we're trying to tackle student
visas there is a massive question about
work visas and the issue is for Jeremy
Hunt the chancellor he needs to grow the
economy so he is will put potentially
more sectors uh onto special Visa
schemes in order to do that so there's
an inherent tension in government and in
cabinet over it too okay Beth fantastic
thank you so much